PAVELSKI, JASON ROBERTSON AND
ROOPE HINTZ.
GETS BUMPED BY JESPER
BRATT.GER 6-6-5
HERE ON HOME ICE.
>> Josh: HERE'S LINDHOLM BACK IN
THE LINEUP.
THE SHOTY THE STARS BEHIND THE
NET.
LINDELL. SOME
STRONG CHECKING WORK BY THIS
LINE.
LIVE WHALEGHT BACK FOR KLINGBER.
HALF A MINUTE TO GO ON THE POWER
PLAY.
ROBE
THEY GOT THE PENALTY KILLERS TO
CHASE A LITTLE BIT AND C
BUT ALONG THOSE LINES IF YOU'RE
TH
THEY UNDERSTAND THEY NEED
POINTS, THEY'RE IN A PLAYOFF
RACE.
>> Josh: SET UP, LIFTINGHE TWO
TWO ASSISTS IN NEW JERSEY WHEN
THESE TWO TEN THAT MANY
TEAMS.
>> Josh: YEAH.
HERE'S A LOO AHEAD, THAT JUST G
UNDER THE
FOOT
>> Josh: AND FITTING THAT 16
SHOTS IN THE GAME, 1
ROBERTSON, PUCK ON HIS STICK ON
TO CLEAR.
NOW WILL SK JAKE OETTINGER BACK
ON TRACK A LITTLE BIT, S OUTER .
SAVE MADE.
REBOUND.
STARS TRYING TO GETET
RIGHT SIDE.
WILL SPREAD OUT
ROBERTSON'S TRYING TO BUMP ITAC.
KLINUT KILLED
JOE PAVELSKI WITH THAT SHOT.
>> Josh: KLINGBERG.
IT'S THE BREAK-THROUGH.
SIZZLER-WRISTER ZING, I DON'T
THIN
SUBBAN DIDN'T HAVE A STICK.
HE GETS BACK UP.
>> Josh: THE DEVILS WIN THESHOO
TY SMITH. D-MEN IS
RETURN FROM JOHNSSON.
AND SHARANGOVICH, OFF THE
I THINK OETTINGER GOT JUST A
TICK OF THAT BLAST AND THEN IT
WENT THE OFFYEAR, AND WITH 1:11
LEFT IN THE RAMS HOME THE
GO-AHEAD GOAL WITH 1:11 TO GO IN
HERE'S A CHANCE.
ZACHA SCORES.
BANG-BANG COMBO FROM THE DEVILS